alles hat man damals versprochen drei
jahre nach der letzten wahl
bildungs und finanzreformen und ein
bisschen
sind sie für die frauenquote in der cdu
wir haben sie sie haben sie wie oft muss
merkel dennoch kandidieren bis sie die
frauenquote im alleingang erfüllen kann
das ist nicht lustig das ist politik
wollen sie kandidieren
sie haben das ja ich würde dich zu
schaffen ja das ringen mit aber kann ich
für eine andere partei kandidieren sie
wirken extrem gut gelaunt trotz dieses
desaströsen jahres für die cdu ist dass
optimismus oder naivität leichter zu
sagen was war denn der größte erfolg der
cdu 2016
ich glaube dass große schwierig zu sagen
dafür kann sie jetzt so spontan endlich
nichts ein
herr vogel sie gelten als
hoffnungsträger der cdu das pferd mich
das bin ich vielleicht einmal gewesen
aber das bin ich bestimmt heute nicht
mehr
wann wird merkel weg sein oder anders
gefragt wann sind sie wieder da ich bin
ja hier und mehr wird daraus nicht mehr
werden sehen wir die lage ist fatal
schall und rauch in das erneuern und die
senkung der steuern
das burka verbot war ja ein thema das
2016 von bedeutungen war wie stehen sie
dazu
ich bin dabei ein burka-verbot ich bin
dabei burka verbot weil das geht nicht
um islam und gegen religion oder so was
nein das geht nur mit sicherheit zum
beispiel an eine frau fährt mit einem
zwei oder burka wenn mir kam es nicht
und dann diese blitz ist wer weiß dass
wir hat diese autos gut das könnte man
ja vermeiden in denen man frauen nicht
auto fahren muss
was wünschen sie sich 2017 für die cdu
einen klaren wahlsieg und einfach das
verhindern von der rot rot grünen
bundesregierung wenn es eine gäbe
sagen sie einfach ein paar farben oder
ob sie wirklich ahnung von politik
ich sage ihnen die farben die für die
parteien stehen
einer nach dem andern namen
kommen sie auch mitgeklatscht minuten
lang war das nicht unangenehm dass man
irgendwie nicht wusste wann hört man auf
zu klatschen
es kann jeder selber entscheiden jeder
ist ein freier mensch und kann auch
pausen warten haben sie eine pause
gemacht zwischendurch ja gut klatschen
funktioniert ja nur mit pause sonst hat
man einfach die hände zusammen
was wünschen sie berufe 2017 viel erfolg
für deutschland
sie sind ja wirklich ein sonnenschein
warum cdu 2016 acht cdu
wie machst du
[Musik]
[Applaus]